hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my agents of shield finale
video so much happen in the finale it
was totally amazing and it teases a lot
of things that they might be able to do
in the future so a lot of things from
the comic so I'll explain what that is
also some really important dates to
agent Carter is going to premiere
January 6 with a two-hour first episode
it'll run for eight episodes total then
agents of shield will come back and it's
going to cross over with Avengers age of
Ultron so I'll explain that after I talk
about the episode whole lot of really
awesome comic book things that we have
to talk about from the episode but
starting with top five moments so just
careful for spoilers if you're not
caught up so number five Skye meets her
father for the first time as expected he
turned out to be Calvin Szabo the father
of Daisy Johnson making her the quake
character so much of the fandom had this
theory that it wasn't as big of a reveal
as it would have been if nobody would
have known about it but it was still a
big surprise and I am really happy they
decided to use comic book origins
instead of try to invent something new
there's always minor changes they have
to make just because of the way TV gets
made and brights issues but for the most
part these characters are fair game for
Marvel just to explain his character in
the comics a little bit he does have
powers but he got them in a lab using a
formula he will be in the second half of
the season they will continue to explore
their family relationship I would assume
that he's gonna be in maybe at least
like two or three episodes Skye is going
to be getting to know her mother's side
of the family and Cowell McLaughlin's
character is the back door to that I
wouldn't be surprised if he actually
knows some of those mystery inhuman
characters we saw at the end they didn't
want to paint him as a villain they just
want him to be this misunderstood really
tragic figure they didn't want to take
that away from him playing that kind of
character is probably what attracted
comic laughlin to the series I'm sure he
probably doesn't care about superpowers
or anything like that most really big
actors to get called to do Marvel stuff
typically aren't comic book fans they
get more excited by really complex
characters like this it's just a bonus
that they also have this really awesome
comic book origin story number 4 Ward
and agent 33 are the new Bonnie and
Clyde of the series if it wasn't too
clear what was going on with them she
has to look for a new identity Ward says
I'll help you let's get the hell out of
here I know it seemed like Skye shot him
but it's just like a Whitehall situation
unless you see them disintegrate in
front of your eyes like
they're not confirmed dead so they're
just gonna be on the run I think the
reason she still has Mays face is
because they want a tie Brett Dalton to
the rest of the cast but they want him
to be off on his own and they don't want
to have to hire like a billion other
actors so it's a way to keep cost down
to keep the cast from getting too big
and a way to visually linked him to the
shield team so he won't be rejoining
Coulson's team Coulson still hates his
guts everyone else pretty much thinks
he's a dirtbag but he's still a really
awesome character he's still really
interesting so he's gonna continue to
have adventures and cross paths with
team Coulson and Skye it's just most of
his adventures will be with agent 33
which I'm actually pretty excited about
she's like his new sidekick I think it's
just gonna be a really awesome
opportunity for me not to play a
different type of character while
wearing the same face that's another
thing too it's like Stephen Amell on
arrow where he plays young Oliver and
old Oliver and they're both very
different characters even though he kind
of looks the same I mean it's the same
person
number 3 Whitehall down it's the same
thing with the Mack reveal in the last
episode you know he fell down that giant
hole so the big WTF is gonna be whenever
we see them again and go oh my god he's
not dead too bad that's probably not
gonna happen with Tripp I think whenever
we got that Whitehall episode I
explained that what I thought Whitehall
did was take all of her internal organs
this guy's father kind of confirmed that
her power involves long life but I think
there's a regeneration component to that
so I think he's just gonna heal himself
it would be totally awesome if we saw
him turn into like some freakish monster
by the end of the series but I think now
he's going to be involved in chasing
down some of these other inhuman
characters it seems like they've kind of
been hiding out so he might not know
about them he didn't really know about
the diviner so I'm guessing he does not
know about these secret inhuman
characters living in society as a
villain he was relatively minor this
first half of the season we didn't see
him that much I mean he's already one of
the heads of Hydra in terms of villains
you can't get much bigger than that but
he hasn't really been chasing down the
shield characters that much he just been
floating in the background doing this
shield land grab thing number two the
Terrigen crystal activates
Raina's and Skye's powers just to
explain that was the Terrigen crystal
inside there there were a lot of
theories I think Terrigen crystal was
one of the leading ones the other theory
was that you know there might have been
an infinity stone in there I didn't
think that was gonna happen just because
that feels like a very movie thing
Infinity stones Terrigen crystal is kind
of a
for grabs though and now we know that
there are several Terrigen crystals
scattered all over the world and they're
all connected it's right out of the
comics it's not something that they
really had to change they did make the
transition a little bit more subtle
usually there's a lot more missed in the
comics and there's a lot more crystals
like it's usually a crystal chamber
instead of just one crystal the big
question I know everyone has is you know
which characters in the comics they are
like I said Skye Daisy Johnson aka quake
from the characters
she's a shield character also works with
the Avengers pretty much anybody with a
computer had this theory so it's like
the least surprising thing ever I think
the most interesting thing about her is
the way they're gonna express those
powers in the way she's gonna be using
them in the back half of the season like
that's the interesting part her learning
to use her powers because it's a TV
budget they're not gonna get too crazy
with it
it's basically seismic abilities and
that just means I'm shaking the camera a
whole lot Raina is a little bit more of
a question mark she looks like she's
getting cat-like abilities there are a
couple characters that fit that bill
there's this really minor in human
character called minxie it was part of
this small arc that got involved with
Medusa she was a relatively minor
character the big character that I'm
really hoping she is is actually Tigre
she wasn't an inhuman in the comics she
was like a b-level Avenger but she ended
up getting her powers through this
really weird ritual but Tigre is way
more exciting because of what it might
mean so what I'm really hoping they do
is just give her tigress character and
then just change the backstory a little
bit it's a bit of a long shot but Tigre
was this really big character in
Avengers Academy most recently so it
could be a back door for them doing
Avengers Academy or even Runaways
Runaways is actually a comic that Joss
Whedon wrote on and he's like king of
the Avengers right now at Marvel so that
would be just so amazing if they did
something like that in the future season
it's a little soon for them to do that
they don't have that many inhuman
characters on screen so I think it's too
soon to do Avengers Academy Runaways
would be something first there'd be like
them chasing down characters these
inhuman characters and trying to help
them in like a very x-men type situation
all things to get excited about for the
future it's just a really big place they
could take things in season three or
season four and my number one moment of
course Inhumans post-credits teaser
there are many of them all over the
world
the big question is is how many of them
are there and are they all together or
are they scattered and everyone's
wondering who that character is without
the eyes there is this new blank
character in the comics called reader if
possible that it's him he's part of that
new run of Inhumans so you should start
reading the Inhumans comics like the
recent ones if you really want to catch
up with that stuff he said that he would
you know quote unquote
take care of it meaning that he's gonna
track down sky they don't seem like
they're villainous characters so I think
that Coulson will try to help them once
they start to cross paths the Inhumans
have always been a very insular society
they have worked with the Avengers but
they've never been buddy-buddy even
Black Bolt is very standoffish so don't
expect those Inhumans like these new
characters that we'll meet in the second
half of the season to join shield think
of it as an early look of what an
Avengers Inhumans team-up might look
like an infinity war let me know that
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and here's my big question for
you guys which character from the comics
do you want Raina to be why you guys
think about that here's a couple other
important things we need to mention the
fate of protocol that was a measure of
last resort theta is a type of brainwave
and protocol could refer to the
activation of assets in terms of people
or tech Iron Man in the comics activated
all of his armor suits simultaneously
with a similar-sounding protocol
wouldn't it be crazy though if it was
like a life model decoy activation I
don't think it has anything to do with
activating the Avengers although that
movie is going to crossover with the TV
series in the spring overall in general
I gave the episode a solid b-plus I mean
it was a great mid-season finale they
technically did some really amazing
things big omage to the comics so they
took some big chances I was really happy
with that but I feel like their cast has
just gotten too big to service all the
characters the way they need to be
serviced one of the advantages to having
a smaller cast is that you can spend
more time with each person like trip
dying should have been a huge thing but
it felt almost offhanded I know they
tried to milk the moment whenever she
was getting her powers whatever Skye was
getting her powers but just the way he
died felt so casual like he just slowly
stepped into the chamber and said oh hey
I came to get you and then he died that
just didn't land for me trip deserved
better
he was actually really awesome character
I'm gonna miss him and yes I do think
that he's dead just to talk about Skye's
character now because she's the one
that's going through the biggest change
well her and Raina but I felt like
season 1 was centered on her so this is
just a natural extension of that
storyline
Coulson always feels like the main
character but really I think the show is
told from her perspective
I think there are just too many
characters like I said so sometimes it
gets a little confusing I am a big fan
of Chloe Bennet I always loved the
behind the scenes stuff that she posts
like they're really funny behind the
scenes just like most actors are even if
their characters are really serious if
it seems like her performance is a
little inconsistent I think that's just
because of them having to service all
these storylines I'm really hoping that
they just drill down on her in the
second half of the season Mina didn't
get a whole lot in this episode I feel
like she's gonna actually get some more
interesting stuff with this agent 33
side storyline I really hope they do let
her keep that face and she gets to be
like these two characters in the same
show my other lesser complaint is the
Kyle MacLachlan character I feel like
he's just written to be a little too
nuts I feel like that performance went
just a little over the line like it got
a little too tongue-in-cheek for me like
a little too on-the-nose I'd like to see
him a little bit more like Mark
Ruffalo's Hulk character whenever he's
in Hulk form on all great episode so
what's gonna be happening now is is I'll
be doing bonus videos in the off season
I'll start doing some agent Carter
videos too and we get closer to that
remember it's a two-hour premiere
January 6 it's gonna air on ABC in the
same timeslot that shield normally airs
so whichever channel you watch shield on
that's the channel you'll watch agent
carter on so whenever that comes most of
my focus is gonna shift to that it's
gonna be a lot of fun there will be some
loose crossover probably with this
Inhumans plot but it'll be way way in
the past
they'll have their own storyline but I
think they'll loosely connect to what's
been going on on agents of shield that's
Marvel's big thing everything is
connected so just look forward to that
be sure to subscribe to get all those
videos if there's any specific bonus
videos you guys want I know a lot of you
guys been asking for Inhumans videos so
I'll definitely do some of those just to
address the Avengers age of Ultron
crossover previously it was thought that
BJ Britt that Tripps character was gonna
crossover that was just a rumor he was
seen on this set the biggest thing we've
heard officially about it is that the
crossover isn't going to affect agents
of shield like the events of age of
Ultron won't affect shield the TV show
as much as Winter Soldier
so the crossover itself will be much
more minor don't forget tonight - arrow
mid-season finale so that's gonna be
really exciting right now if you guys
are on your mobile phone or on your
tablet there's new mobile links up here
that you can click on it's the same as
the links over here but click here to
learn more about the Inhumans movie and
click here for all my other shield
videos thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five I will see you guys
tonight
you